Nataly Colts family responds to the  Grammys and they're still upset over the  show's tribute to the late singer  I'm fine  that's how the Grammys honored the late  Natalie Cole on Monday night after  Natalie's sisters expressed their dismay  can Elric a longtime producer of the  show defended the tribute to billboard  saying the clip was the most touching  and emotional tribute he could have  presented now Tim Allen and Casey Cole  and Robert Yancey are responding in a  written statement given exclusively to  et they say quote while we acknowledge  there was good intention on the part of  the Grammys to honor our sister and  mother it did not come through and quote  she meant too much she was too much and  she deserved better  the overwhelming sadness is echoed by  her millions of fans all over the world  who we have been hearing from after all  perception is reality it was an oops